- [Interviewer] Neahbbahh.
- Hello.
- [Interviewer] Neahbbahh,
that's an unusual name.
How do you spell it?
- N-E-A-H-B-B-A-H-H
- [Interviewer] Wow.
(both laugh)
- [Interviewer] Where
are you from originally?
- [Neahbbahh] Originally,
Boston, Massachusetts.
- [Interviewer] Boston. And,
you grew up with both parents?
One parent?
- [Neahbbahh] I grew up with
my mom and my stepfather.
- [Interviewer] And
how was your childhood?
- It was crazy.
My father was a drug dealer.
Engineer, drug dealer.
(laughs)
Engineer by day, drug dealer at night.
I saw a lot of crazy things growing up.
Things I probably shouldn't have seen.
Abuse. Physical, sexual.
- [Interviewer] From who?
From stepdad, or dad?
- No, from uncles. Just physical abuse,
mental abuse from my mother.
My father, well, my
stepfather was there a lot.
Never abused me. Kind of protected me,
so I love him very much.
He was always a protector.
- [Interviewer] It's nice
to have somebody lookout.
- Yeah, he protected me from my mom a lot.
- [Interviewer] From your mom?
- Mhm. Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And the sexual
abuse, what age did it start?
- About...
four or five.
- [Interviewer] Really?
- Mhm.
- [Interviewer] There's
a lot of it or just-
- Yeah, a lot of it.
Anytime
they would get a chance.
My mother wasn't a very vigilant person.
She believed that if you were
like, from the same culture,
you wouldn't hurt someone like that.
She just had real
ignorant beliefs
and thoughts,
and never believed a word I said.
- [Interviewer] What age
were you when you left home?
- I didn't leave home, my
mother threw me out. I was 13.
- [Interviewer] Your
mom threw you out at 13?
- In the winter, five
days before Christmas.
- [Interviewer] Five
days before Christmas?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Where
did you go from there?
- I went to go live with a
pimp and his prostitutes,
and I started selling crack for them.
- [Interviewer] You weren't
having sex for money?
- No.
I was always really afraid of men
because of what happened
to me when I was younger,
but then I did end up meeting
someone that ended up abusing me
even more and making me
more unstable than I was,
Older gentlemen, you know?
Now I look back on it
and I'm like, a predator.
He was a predator back then,
and that made my life even more,
my mental states spin out of control.
I did continue going to
school and educate myself,
and I was never able to really hold down.
I've gotten great jobs,
never been able to hold a city
job down because of my mind,
just racing thoughts all the time.
Things have happened to me, you know?
So, I think I was 27 when
I started using heroin.
I was 27.
That was the first time the
noise shut off in my head.
- [Interviewer] Shut off the pain?
- Just shut off.
Pain.
- [Interviewer] I've heard that a lot.
- Everything, it just went away.
It wasn't the most pleasant experience,
because I threw up and it was just gross,
but the thought of me not thinking
about things that have
happened to me, the thought
of not jumping when
there's a certain noise.
I was diagnosed with severe PTSD
and bipolar schizoaffective,
but that was all after the abuse.
Yeah, and then I used for...
27, so I was 35, I believe?
And then I stopped for a while.
Then I met my husband,
and then...
my whole world crashed.
I lost everything. I lost my children.
I lost...
I lost all sense of stability, I lost.
When we got together, him and I.
- [Interviewer] Why is that?
- Because I didn't know he
was a raging drug addict,
and then that just triggered
my addiction as well,
so I started using again,
and he was severely abusive.
Physically abusive for many years.
We were together for seven years,
and for seven years I was beat
from morning till late.
He took me away from my children,
took me away from my family.
We ended up here in California.
Within six months of being here,
he got four prostitutes pregnant.
He himself started
prostituting himself to men,
and now he's involved
in this sex trafficking
thing that they do down here in Skid Row.
I've been held hostage
in tents because of him.
I've been raped.
That sex ring place told him
to allure me there,
so he lured me there
and they had him watch,
and while they raped me, beat me.
My own husband.
He robbed me for my,
my pension.
He's done horrible things to me.
Has had me beat up,
so that I wouldn't go down the street
where they're at,
so I wouldn't witness or hear anything,
but I have and it's just the worst thing
in the world just to
witness something like that.
That even spun my addiction worse,
like out of control
worse dealing with that,
and I haven't contacted my family.
- [Neahbbahh] Just these
people walked in his life and
hearing him getting raped,
and a part of me is like, good.
That's karma for what you did to me,
but at the end of the day,
that's a human being, you know?
You don't deserve that.
None of us deserve what's
happening to us down here.
You don't know who to trust.
You don't know what cup to drink
because you don't know what
they're gonna do to you.
There's parasites down here.
People dying from parasites,
like worms and stuff
coming out of their bodies.
You just have to be
extremely cautious down here.
I used to tell my husband,
this is like the first level of hell,
because it's horrible.
Like if you sit down by the
end of Crocker at night,
all you hear is screaming
from all these people
that are being held
hostage in tents and stuff,
and nobody does anything
because, what can you do?
If you say anything or do anything,
you're gonna be next.
Today I'm just gonna get myself together
and go to treatment
and get out of here.
I came to California with a purpose.
I wanted to publish my books.
I write screenplays
and I write books, poetry.
We came here with a plan,
so I'm just gonna have to carry it out,
because I came here with a purpose that
I'm gonna to do what I
came here to do, you know?
- [Interviewer] Do you have
contact with your kids,
or family, or anything?
- No. My daughter, beautiful woman.
She's gorgeous.
I don't know where, I
know they're in Boston,
but I don't have her number.
I don't have contact with my son.
I have a little girl, her name's Ivory.
She lives in Texas.
They've been trying to get to her,
cause she's also involved
in a lot of stuff,
and I really want to be with my children,
especially my baby.
My daughter, but I can't
find them anywhere.
I've left messages on Facebook and stuff.
You know when I tell you this man
took me away from everyone, he
took me away from everything,
but it's just up to me now
to get strong and motivated.
Just keep looking forward,
and don't look back,
cause I have a plan and
I have dreams and goals
that I want to accomplish,
and I want to try my
best to get with them.
Because this isn't life for anyone.
I weigh 80 pounds.
80 pounds.
Sick, I'm very sick now,
and I haven't even
gone to the hospital because
I think
the drug is so powerful.
One has plans, but one
doesn't carry them out
because this is just, it takes over.
It takes the essence of
who you are in a way.
Very essence of your spirituality,
who you are, is gone.
You're just an empty shell,
and I don't want to
feel like that anymore.
- [Interviewer] How many
years have you been down here?
- I've been down here for a
year, now this time around.
- [Interviewer] Just a year?
- Yeah, just a year, and within that year,
everything's gone,
and the only thing I still
have is my education,
and at least I still have
some sense of sensibility.
- [Interviewer] Well Neahbbahh,
thank you for talking again,
and good luck with your future
and getting off the streets.
- Yes, definitely. Thank you.